on va vivre cette femme vient de fêter
ses sons amputé des deux jambes elle n'a
plus toutes ses facultés physiques ce
sont ses enfants qui s'occupent d'elle
c'est un peu grâce à elle si toutes les
personnes présentes à l'inauguration de
la Maison des aidants du Lorrain vont
retrouver l'espoir de vivre une semaine
vie soulager les aidants de leur
quotidien plutôt lourd c'est la mission
première de l'association qui gère les
lieux d'ailleurs d'entrer une des futurs
intervenantes l'aimait déjà en
conditions de détente
en général malheureusement dans la
première sur la première ligne et sont
plus
vulnérable donc c'est important qu'il se
rendent compte qu'ils prennent du temps
pour leur bonne santé et la santé c'est
quoi c'est bien dormir bien manger bien
boire trouver le temps pour soi pour
pouvoir avoir de la joie de sourire et
même si ça fait de la peine d'avoir
quelqu'un qui est malade
à l'intérieur c'est comme à la maison
avec en plus une salle dédiée à
l'informatique et Internet d'ailleurs
les ordinateurs sont déjà prêts à être
branchés après initiation les aidants
pourront enfin accéder à certaines
démarches sans se déplacer et surtout
sortir du cadre pesant de la maladie
je retrouve quelques idées que je nous
lis personnellement déjà le jardin
thérapeutique je trouve ça très
intéressant c'est une manière
de se déconnecter de la réalité que
d'avoir la main dans la terre
il aura fallu trois longues années pour
que la maison des aidants familiaux du
Lorrain voit le jour aucune instance
locale n'a financer le projet
l'association a dû faire appel à un
mécène
nous sommes allés frapper aux portes des
fondations en France à Paris et nous
avons réussi à trouver les fonds à la
Banque Transatlantique par le biais
d'une de flanc de dotation jolimi voilà
vous avez fait des demandes ici bah
écoutez nous avons déjà demandé à mettre
en place des partenariats des
conventions qui vont permettre justement
de après l'avoir défend mais pour le
moment nous n'avons pas encore de
réponse alors pour le moment la CTM nous
a dit qu'ils vont nous accompagner nous
n'avons pas encore défini les contours
de la Convention sur les plus de 6700
habitants du Lorrain il faut compter
près de 3900 seniors cela fait beaucoup
de personnes à accompagner la maison des
aidants familiaux prévoit aussi de
prendre en charge tous les aidants du
Nord Atlantique une seule structure de
ce type pour plus de 50 000 habitants
dans un pays vieillissant cela relève de